As the X-Men square off against Apocalypse
and his four horsemen, there's no shortage
of spoilerific secrets in the latest mutant
slugfest. If there's anything to learn from
Apocalypse taking on Professor X's band of
heroes, it's that the 1980s and the ancient
evil villain are both pretty much immortal.
Put on your neon-colored parachute pants.
We've made you an X-Men: Apocalypse Easter
egg omelette so dense you'd need adamantium
claws to cut through it. And just in case
you missed it, here’s your final warning:
there are major spoilers ahead!
Jabs at The Last Stand
One of X-Men: Apocalypse's most meta Easter
eggs comes while some young mutants pull a
Ferris Bueller and ditch a school day, hitting
up the mall instead. Surprisingly, the Dazzler
record scene we've seen in pictures prior
to the film's release was nowhere to be found
in the actual film. Instead, the group takes
a few jabs at the more underwhelming parts
of the X-Men film franchise. As the four mutant
teens leave a showing of Return of the Jedi,
they joke about how sequels always end up
being much darker than the first film. Even
though they’re talking about Star Wars,
it’s also a pretty clear reference to X2:
X-Men United. Jean Grey adds that everyone
knows that the third movie is almost always
the weakest of the bunch, which is almost
definitely a zinger aimed at X-Men: The Last
Stand — the third movie in the franchise that
most fans pretend never happened. In case
you were wondering, frequent X-Men director
Bryan Singer skipped out on filming The Last
Stand in favor of Superman Returns.
Return of The Blob
In a callback to Wolverine's debut in the
original X-Men film and X-Men Origins: Wolverine,
we’re treated to some mutant-filled, underground
fights. Before we see Angel taking on Nightcrawler,
we see a familiar face laid out on the ground
from a previous fight. This is Fred Dukes,
better known as The Blob. Dukes being flat
on his back is probably a callback to his
appearance in Origins. This time, he looks
even more comic-accurate. Good luck to the
guys who had to carry him out of the ring.
Star Trek appreciation
Bryan Singer isn't ashamed of being a Trekkie.
When we visit Storm's home, her television
is playing the original Star Trek series'
season two episode, "Who Mourns for Adonais."
This Trek episode foreshadows future events
with Apocalypse, as it focuses on the team
encountering a powerful god-like character
who can grow to amazing heights. Sound familiar? Singer also
appeared as an uncredited crew member in Star
Trek: Nemesis, taking orders from the original
Professor X himself, Patrick Stewart.
Stan Lee's cameo co-star
We've seen Stan Lee cameo as a postman, Hugh
Hefner, Larry King, an intergalactic ladies'
man, and even a strip club DJ. In X-Men: Apocalypse,
Lee's role is much simpler. We see him react
to something horrific. The big difference
from his previous cameos is who's with him
this time around. With Lee during this scene
is his real-life wife, Joan.
Reloading Weapon X
The last X-Men: Apocalypse trailer teased
Hugh Jackman's return for the we've-lost-counteenth
time as Wolverine. The film gives Logan his
adamantium skeleton from the Weapon X program,
rewriting Origins' story even further, along
with his trademark, trauma-induced berserker
rage. Best of all, Jackman actually wears
the iconic Weapon X headgear, straight from
the comics. Don't hold your breath for the
character's famous yellow spandex costume though.
Another Order of the Phoenix
Speaking of Wolverine, the character's longtime
love interest Jean Grey is only in her teens
during the film, and she's still struggling
to control her powers. Jean Grey has nightmares
about what's going to happen, teasing the
inevitable fight against Apocalypse's forces.
She also alludes to seeing flames and a darkness
inside her, foreshadowing her character's
eventual possession by the cosmic entity known
as the Phoenix.
In both X-Men: The Last Stand and the original
comic books, Jean struggles with controlling
the fiery Phoenix before it takes over completely,
turning her into one of the series' most powerful
villains. Towards the end of X-Men: Apocalypse,
Jean throws her worries out the window after
Xavier tells her to go all out on Apocalypse.
Jean turns her powers on full blast, resulting
in a flaming bird aura appearing around her,
teasing the Phoenix for a future entry of
the series. Yes, we got chills from it, and
so will you. Hopefully if they revisit the
Phoenix saga in future movies, it'll go a
little better this time around.
That Sinister post-credits scene
As usual the movie's post-credits scene will
leave comic junkies jumping for joy, while
the average moviegoer will just have to wait
until a comic fan explains it to them. The
final scene features a man in a suit exploring
the ruins of William Stryker's Weapon X compound.
As a cleanup crew tries mopping up the mess
of bullets and bodies, the man grabs some
Weapon X samples and stows them in his briefcase.
The briefcase snaps shut, showing a logo of
a company named "Essex Corp."
Comics fans know that Nathaniel Essex, also
known as Mr. Sinister, is a longtime villain
of the X-Men. He frequently collaborates with
Apocalypse, and he's obsessed with Jean Grey
and Scott Summers' genetics. He goes as far
as creating a clone of Jean Grey, Madelyne
Pryor, who Scott Summers marries and has a
kid with. That child turns out to be Cable,
Deadpool's time-traveling buddy. This could
set up Mr. Sinister in a future X-Men film
and maybe even the fan favorite character
of X-23, a young female clone of Wolverine.
If 20th Century Fox is looking for a way to
make more Wolverine movies after Hugh Jackman
hangs up his claws, bringing X-23 into the
fold may just do the trick...
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which Easter Egg from X-Men: Apocalypse
was your favorite...